who doesn't love a good sandwich or what
about some good music this morning we're
introducing you to one chef who's
combining both worlds brian sao has
cooked in some of new york city's best
restaurants like beauty and essex and he
even won the competition show beat bobby
flay on the food network now sao is at
the helm of his own sandwich shop which
opened in may for our series the dish i
visited mission sandwich social in
brooklyn williamsburg to be exact where
all sandwiches have a twist of rock and
roll and i even got a little jam session
in with the chef
we're going to go with some of this herb
mayo which has rosemary thyme
and fresh oregano at mission sandwich
social in brooklyn chef brian sau taps
into his fine dining experience it's a
play on a classic italian
combo of melon and prosciutto
to bring unique flavors with a flair of
rock and roll it was called the post
melon or the post malone to elevate the
humless of foods the sandwich everything
is so harmonious everything is working
together it's almost like a song a
progression sour sandwiches start with a
secret recipe dutch crunch bread maybe
i'll give you the exclusive behind the
scenes one one of these days but for now
it remains a secret each sandwich has a
vegetarian option i wanted people to
still be able to experience the sandwich
the way it was meant to be with a
vegetarian option and they're all
infused with his passion for food and
music
[Music]
the two worlds i wanted to bring
together was the world of rock and roll
heavy metal and you know new york city
urban culture and kind of blend the two
and i think this is a very good
representation of who i am as a person
when he's not in the kitchen you can
find sau rocking out with his band loss
becomes his love of music goes as far
back as his love of cooking i grew up
with a taiwanese father a korean mother
but growing up having western food was
always a treat the memories ingrained in
my mind of these big saucy subs you know
just meaty and you know the the sauce
would be dripping down my hand i never
had something like that in my life but i
was like i can make something like this
and i was only
13 14 years old and before you know it a
week later there's a meat slicer to my
on the kitchen counter at my house to my
mom's dismay and and uh yeah and and and
my dad had me making sandwiches for
lunch for the staff on weekends even at
that early age know that you wanted to
cook no no not at all it's pretty common
in asian culture you know a chef
profession is kind of looked down upon
when i told my parents i wanted to be a
chef they were definitely like oh no my
kid my kid wants to be a chef and now
they won't shut up about it be like hey
guess what my son is a chef you know so
we're going to start with this
short rib that's been marinated in my
mom's recipe and
we're going to start
with ranch dressing his signature
sandwich is his mom's korean barbecue or
bogogi recipe all right i'm going to put
some of this sauce directly onto the
meat along with some fresh mozzarella
okay okay so this is gochugaru rice wine
vinaigrette gochugaru is
a korean chili flake tiny bit more sauce
and there's a purpose for that okay it's
so that when i put the fries on
no way
this is america baby it's america
and no korean meal is complete without
some kimchi i'm gonna close this up wow
this thing is huge
[Music]
okay cheers cheers thank you
i'm drooling i'm drooling as i'm biting
into it it's never happened to me before
when i'm opening up my mouth to eat
something and drool he hopes to create
memories with his sandwiches and hook
customers just the way music does
there's something about like a good
guitar hook the way it sits in the
frequency range it just captures you
[Music]
every time i make a sandwich there's got
to be something about it that hooks you
in where you go ah
i need to try that sao spent his days
building out his restaurant concept and
taste testing his menu when many
businesses were forced to shudder due to
the pandemic what did it mean to you
during the pandemic and subsequent to it
to see some of the violence perpetrated
against people in the aapi community it
got me very concerned for my parents for
my wife for my daughter
it got me concerned for the fellow asian
person i've never met before but i also
made it a mission of mine to be the best
version of myself i know that my actions
will speak much louder than any of those
violent acts can he's now a force and a
representative in the food industry and
hopes to connect people with what he
calls the universal language food is big
time the universal language it hits them
to their soul like that feeling can only
come from food and it's something that's
understood by everybody from every
culture and every place when you give
someone really good food it just it like
goes straight to the heart man
we're big fans right
[Laughter]
where are the sandwiches glad i talked
to brian earlier this morning he's going
to bring some sandwiches for us no
problem i was going to say i love how
you called them harmonious sandwiches
but we cannot harmonize with them
exactly because you did not bring up any
sandwiches honestly all jokes aside
were they as good as they looked because
they looked great guys i i was not
kidding when i said i was drooling when
i was taking a bite and i took like
seven of them home my wife and i were
eating them every day for the next three
days so delicious thank you we're
looking forward to the sandwiches